oh it's nice i spoke to the leading
british fertility expert Lord Winston I
began by asking him his thoughts about
this procedure well I think it's really
interesting I'm very glad that they've
done it it seems an important thing to
have done it's not entirely you because
of course actually the technology is
British it was first on in edinburgh by
david baird and Roger Gosselin quite a
long time ago in sheep and then since
then an American surgeon has done some
of this work but not for a cancer victim
so all that will always recognize that
cancer victims might be an ideal op it
might be an opportunity this is new in
that respect and the reason why it's
possible it's because the ovary which is
a sphere has a skin which is absolutely
chock full of eggs the interior doesn't
have many eggs but the skin of the ovary
is full so if you can just peel off a
bit of the skin and then freeze that and
replace it later on you do have a
probability of being able to get that to
ovulate I mean one has heard before
people going in for treatment being told
that they should save some eggs as it
were so that that has happened but not
for cancer before yes but not for cancer
the trauma is that egg freezing is not a
very attractive technology because it's
not easy to do it was much more fiddling
around them this stance because this is
a pretty simple procedure you can do it
any stage during the menstrual cycle you
don't need to prepare the patient with
drugs and you do an afro scopic
examination that's a telescope through
the abdomen and you take a piece of the
every way the problem with it is that in
taking the bits of ovary aware you may
scar it and therefore cause infertility
at a later date but it seems to me that
if your are suffering from cancer you
know you want to try everything to try
on a soil fertility and I know from
experience of many people who've got
kinds of problems during that they're
actually more worried about the
fertility issue when they've have the
drugs afterwards in the variation that's
the thing which frightens them because
people with cancer nowadays expect to
live I mean rightly of course but the
consequences of the treatment the side
effects of the treatment which are often
causing sterility are very serious but
to Menem to win why is it that cancer
treatment can cause
because the eggs in the RV are very
sensitive to radiation and they're very
sensitive to the drugs which are given
to developing cells and of course that
applies to males as well so what happens
in the ovary it will also have another
test is but we're not just talking about
people who have cancer the testes or
cancer of the womb and we're talking
about we have cancer in general indeed
but yeah nowadays more cancerous treated
by drugs and of course the drugs are
effective you systemic venous the whole
body so if you were having lung cancer
treatment or liver cancer treatment of
brain cancer treatment the probabilities
you might be having chemotherapy which
would affect your ovaries or your
testers that would also affect your
fertility yeah and are there any ethical
problems in this i think the ethical
problems which really will need to be
teased out are whether or not you might
cause an abnormality in the baby but
actually i think really the probability
is your prevent abnormalities because of
course one of the issues with
chemotherapy is that by treating
somebody who's eggs then recover you may
actually induce an abnormality because
they were not protected by being removed
from the environment which caused the
disturbance so that's one problem the
other issue which has been talked about
for some time is that if you take a
piece of ovary away you may take some
cancer cells so when you replace the
ovary you might replace some cancer
cells which then regenerate I think it's
probably a theoretical objection of
course the other thing is that the woman
has to have enough of her body left that
she can then grow grow a baby yes it is
only going to be really valuable for
teenagers probably maybe younger people
occasionally and for young people who
get cancer but of course cancer is now
such a disease that really is not
unusual we're treating more more young
people with those diseases successfully
so they're living longer through
childbearing life and you say that this
technology started in this country have
been conducted on a warm do you think
this and will now become fairly
widespread I hope it becomes more
widespread I think one of the real
issues is that sometimes people treating
cancer and sometimes people will be
by cancer are so consumed by the
anxieties of what's going to be facing
them that fertility is rather forgotten
about and certainly in the past one of
the issues has been that on colleges
have not really perhaps rated the
preservation of fertility seriously
enough I think the advantage of this
technique is that it's a pretty quick
intervention doesn't require a great
deal from the patient it does require an
anesthetic but providing there well
enough to have a nun aesthetic which of
course most cancer victims certainly
will be then I think you can then store
these eggs almost indefinitely and
potentially what sort of numbers of
women are we talking about I don't know
at Hammersmith hospital when I was
working there we probably saw about
somewhere between a hundred two hundred
and fifty patients in five years who
looking at having they explored that's
when Santino much